this is Startalk Travis says this one
big issue facing humans especially in
the third world countries is access to
clean drinking water is there a way to
possibly manufacture water through
chemistry or is it just not as simple as
throwing two hydrogen atoms together
with one oxygen atom is it even possible
to create water or is there a finite
amount available on earth that's a great
question it's a good question and you
know it's a huge problem for when we
want to explore the solar system because
if we're going somewhere else where
there's no water then we need to take it
with us or we need to pop by a comet or
an asteroid on the way and you know get
some water from it melt it you know take
it with us because we need water and
humans are not going to survive very
long without it so we want to go to Mars
that again is one of the big challenges
for having humans on Mars because to get
water off the planet is hugely expensive
it's not very efficient to get you know
to launch stuff into space so so this is
a big problem we need yeah we need to
find a way to either mine it on these
planets if there is any water but you
know most of them are bone-dry
that's a big problem but in terms of the
earth we have enough water it's just in
the wrong places most the time if you
know what I mean it's like right we
right exactly
don't you think we need to find a way to
manufacture it it's it's more of a way
of getting clean water we have a lot of
salt water but it's getting the clean
fresh water in the right places Lynne
did you have anything to add I just
agree with you completely there's plenty
of water but too much of is it dirty or
too much of it is salty and we don't
know where to find more clean water and
making that dirty salty water clean is
expensive yeah but you can make water
and I was so excited when I did that in
the lab the first time we were doing
experiments in these little tubes and
that inside the tube was hydrogen and if
you open the tube and the hydrogen
started to burn it makes water because
when you burn hydrogen yeah adds oxygen
oxidizes water Wow and somehow making it
and seeing the drops of water fall down
was
mind blowing to me because you do it
hypothetically you're like in your head
but this was for a meal we were burning
hydrogen and making water yeah and this
is why she's a scientist because we find
these kinds of things interesting that
is very interesting I mean honestly
you're you're you're burning hydrogen to
create water is crazy and that's crazy
that's basically a James Taylor song you
know I mean that's really what it is so
Wow
so now the fact that you've done this in
a lab if we ever got to a place where we
actually had to create water and this is
what what he was saying we would be able
to do that as Travis wants to know we
would be able to create water out of
nothing I think didn't they do this in
the Martian I don't know Matt Damon was
up there doing this it went a bit wrong
didn't it but you know the one you're
burning hydrogen you've got to be a bit
careful yeah okay hey Travis great
question man that was very very cool
wait and let me put an addendum on his
question so you talked about salty water
water being in the wrong place you talk
about salty what are you talking about
dirty water yeah is there now we'll
never run out of water ostensibly
because three-quarters of our planet is
water and we have a water cycle
ecosystem is part is creates the water
cycle yeah is there a way if we stay on
our current course that we would
actually dirty enough water that we will
run out of water is that possible yeah I
guess yeah I don't see why not because
we're not very careful with it and I
guess at some point you know we will
have to find a way to make all the water
clean and that will be hard but we could
you know we can desalinate the seawater
is really expensive and it takes a lot
of energy to like that which is the main
problem right yeah I have no idea
Lindy yeah it's so the simple answer is
yes because it's a finite there's a
finite amount of water so you could make
it all dirty but the thing that I
learned recently that really shocked me
is most of the water that we get is from
wells it's from underground water you
know aquifers right not only do we not
know how much water there isn't
furs on the earth almost none of that is
is legislated governments don't control
how much water you take out of aquifers
almost anywhere so we don't know how
much there is and we're not tracking it
and taking care of it
wow that's worried that's worrisome to
say that that's a crazy so what you're
saying is there's no regulation on the
amount of extraction but there's but
there is also no effort to measure how
much is actually there people are
beginning to work on it but we haven't
we haven't gotten there wow that's a
that's I'm just gonna say that's really
stupid but that's just my opinion okay
civilization we're trying to grow up
we're in a sort of an awkward
adolescence here but all right